[Music]
let me start our announcements with some
updates to the president's agenda as we
informed
yesterday on social media president
vanderlaan is in finland today
the president met this morning president
sauli miniser and she will also meet
prime minister sana marin later today
at around 1 15 pm brussels time she will
hold a press conference with prime
minister marin that you can follow
on ebs
also new to the president's agenda uh on
friday she will receive here in the
bellamon the prime minister of north
macedonia
dimitar kovacevsky i hope i pronounced
that right apologies if i didn't
to continue to let me call christian who
has an announcement on the validity of
the digital kovid certificate
thank you eric
good afternoon
today the european commission adopted a
proposal to extend the eu digital covert
certificate by one year this is until
the 13th of 30th of june 2023
as it stands the covert virus continues
to be prevalent in europe
we also need to be ready for a possible
increase
in infections in the second half of the
year or for the emergence of new
variants
the eu digital covet certificate was put
in place as an exceptional measure
and it continues to be an exceptional
measure
while we look forward to the day when it
will no longer be needed for now we need
to make sure that europeans can travel
safely in the eu and that they can use
the certificates should member states
continue to impose
travel restrictions
we are proposing this extension today to
give the european parliament and the
council
sufficient time to conclude the
legislative process
before the current regulation expires
we are also proposing some limited
amendments to the regulation to make the
lives of citizens easier for instance to
we are proposing to ensure a correct
encoding of vaccination doses for people
who received vaccination in different
member states
or vaccination certificates for people
who took part in clinical trials
you will find the press release online
with more information
[Music]
um
such enthusiasm i cannot resist
go ahead
catherine fiore your reporter indeed
naric
i'm just wondering if there is a
response from the commission
to
yesterday's decision by
a northern irish member or a minister
for
agriculture to suspend uh
suspend checks border checks at the
border um and do you have any comment on
this and then do you have a comment
on the fact that the northern irish
secretary of state and indeed uh the
foreign secretary les trusts have said
that this is a matter
for the northern irish executive do you
consider it to be a matter for the
northern irish executive
thank you
thank you um catherine
to answer your questions of course we
have uh seen
this uh this announcement obviously we
are monitoring the situation on the
ground as you know we have experts who
are on the ground in northern ireland
precisely
in relation to the issue of checks
and finally uh as you i'm sure know full
well uh the protocol that we have signed
has been signed with the british
government uh with her majesty's
government and uh it is for the uk
government uh to ensure the fulfillment
of the agreement
is it on this
i don't think we're going to get away
with one question on this issue joe
thank you eric um you mentioned you've
got your officials going on the grey on
monitoring the situation could you kind
of give us an early insight of what they
found because
we've seen on social media the checks
haven't been suspended or they look like
there were people opening lorries in
haifa's jackets this morning someone's
wondering are you
quietly confident that these checks
wouldn't be suspended in the coming days
thank you well i don't know about the
coming days what i can say is that
preliminary information we have from our
experts on the ground
is indeed that the checks are continuing
any other questions on this
please only keep your hand raised in the
chat
if your questions
are on this yes shona
hi thanks a million um can you hear me
okay
yes
okay great i'm just wondering if the if
this is continues then and there are no
checks uh taking place is that seen as
then the breach of the protocol breach
of international law and could there be
a suspension of the tca as a result as
threatened in the past thanks
thanks jonah look i think it's very
clear that we have an agreement
that foresees uh that these checks
should take place
um i'm not going to go into speculation
about what we would undertake in case
the checks were to stop as i said for
the moment our indications are the
checks are ongoing we will we will take
it from there
and we will come back to the issue if
the situation evolves
naomi
thank you eric um yeah my question is
also on this um how ready would the
commission be to re-activate the legal
procedures that was sort of put on ice
last year um in response to this new
apparent violation of international
agreements thanks thanks now i'm afraid
my answer is going to be the same you
know we don't speculate on what we would
do or would not uh do
the only thing i can
i can say is that as you know there is a
phone call foreseen this afternoon
between vice president zefkovich and
liz truss and this
issue will obviously be raised in the
context of this phone call
okay i think is it still on this
catherine go ahead
i doubt i'm going to get an answer on it
but i'll try anyway
you say what has or hasn't happened you
say the checks are still ongoing and
that's reassuring but the fact of the
matter is the foreign secretary the
person who
uh vice president sevkevich is in
contact with
denies that it is the responsibility of
the british government who are of course
the signatory of the withdrawal
agreement i mean is this
is is that something that you can um
act on that in itself is a problem
that there is such a poor understanding
of what has been agreed to
let me be very clear i don't think that
the commission
is in any way responsible for the
constitutional arrangements uh in
the united kingdom
right we have signed the agreement as i
said previously with the united kingdom
this has been ratified
by both sides and
therefore
for us what counts is not what are the
arrangements that are found within
the united kingdom on who is responsible
for taking what decision when it comes
to the checks but the fact that the
provisions that are in the agreement on
the checks which are foreseen by the
agreement will be respected
and this is certainly a message that
will be passed this afternoon during the
phone call that i mentioned
right
anna in the chat you have raise your
hand is it on the
i doubt it but is it on the
protocol on the issue we've just
discussed
no then
i move on to other issues
thank you it's the rota from polish tv
pulsar well there are two big news
coming from poland today that i would
like you to react to the first one is
polish president duda who announced the
concrete propositions of
dismantling the disciplinary chamber of
the supreme court in poland
i guess this is exactly what the
european commission and the european
court of justice
uh wanted poland to do do you welcome it
what is your reaction and first then the
second
question will be about the tour of mine
thank you
thank you well as you know we don't
react on announcements uh obviously
we react based on our analysis of actual
actual texts
so it's very it's it's too early for us
to uh to make uh any uh announcement or
any to give any reaction to this
announcement sorry we will have to wait
and see uh what exactly is proposed
follow-up
but the dismantling of the disciplinary
chamber of the supreme court that's what
you expect
from from poland according to the
judgment of the european court of
justice that's that's
that's undoubtedly true but um
you have perhaps more information than
we do on what the draft law will include
um but as far as we are concerned we
need to see the full text
um and be in a position to analyze it
before we can uh take a position
obviously on this on this announcement
obviously um anything that goes in the
direction of the conditions that have
been set in particular by the court of
justice uh are uh are something that we
will be looking very attentively into
but again as i say difficult for me to
take a position today on some on the
text we have not seen
yes
when the disciplinary chamber will stop
functioning
will you stop
counting the fines
for poland
so this is this is more
a
more specific question related to the
conditions for the fines to stop
applying so on this i will ask christian
to uh to come because it
relates specifically to the judgment
not to the announcement which was made
today
thank you eric well the old i can just
remind of of what
the court has decided in this context
which is which is very clear
that
the fines apply until
um
uh poland fully complies uh with the
order of the court right so this is what
we've always been asking for um and it
remains uh for poland to fully uh and
urgently comply with the court's order
of 14th july
are there other questions on um
on this subject more generally i see a
certain number of hands raised in the
chat please only keep your hand raised
if it is
on
this
that is not um not the case so i come
back to um
odile who had um sorry we'll stay with
questions to christian so if you have a
rule of law question related to
christian i think now is the right time
to take it tibor
i think you have a question for
christian
yes can you hear me yes go ahead
yeah
uh my question concerns christian's
previous announcement at the beginning
of the midday
uh the connection between
vaccinations and free travel
previously
the eu citizens who received
for example the russian
or the chinese vaccines could only
travel within the eu if they had a pcr
test or spend some days in current in
is there any change in these rules and
what happens with those who
have one russian or chinese vaccination
plus another one
or
with an ema approved vaccine or two
russian and chinese vaccines and then
ema approved booster
is there any change in these cases
yes thanks thanks for your question
deeper
no there is no there is no change with
today's update of the regulation that we
are proposing
um
the the principle
has always been that um
that
ema
approved vaccines need to be accepted by
member states while uh for other
vaccinations it is a decision for the
member states like if they are on the
whole list et cetera
having said that
let me also clarify that
your vaccination certificate that you
receive always shows the last dose
that you have received
so in that case if if your last dose
shows an emma approved vaccine
then your vaccination certificate in
that sense
should be should be accepted
as an emma approved vaccine that you
have received as elastos
so but tibor just to
to be very um
specific when you say that people who
had received the uh for example the
russian vaccine as you said could not
travel is not strictly true
as christian has said there has always
been the possibility for member state to
decide to recognize this vaccine
but if this member state decided to do
this then it had to apply to everybody
who was traveling to the country not
only its own citizens
but also
other
other travelers
i think that's
that's correct
okay
are there other questions
on uh on this issue naomi you have a
question on the vlog on the eudcc
my question is about the announcement
this morning about the extension of the
covet pass legislation i think that fits
in um yes so um
there has been sort of some
kind of talk of this disease covered
becoming endemic at this point um so
that it's uh just gonna be something
that's around and i was wondering you
know how are you taking this into
account when you're looking at extending
the
covert pass or code certificate
legislation um
is is the sort of transition of the
disease into a more endemic status
something that you've taken into account
thank you
christian
well i mean that's
that's probably this question is maybe
from the health side more stefan knows
more about but on the on the certificate
as such i think as i have as i have
clarified in the announcement
it is simply at this point in time clear
that the virus is still
circulating
this is
very prevalent in europe and also that
we need to be ready for further
developments
be it possible
further increases
in in the second half of this year or
emergence of new variants so
we are not we are not out of the woods
yet
uh and so what our objective remains the
same that uh during the pandemic
and it's the same that it has been from
the beginning so that during the
pandemic we
help citizens facilitate
their lives by facilitating safe uh free
travel within the european union through
the eu digital corporate certificate
which which has been taken up very
successfully with more than 1.2 billion
certificates issued by now
so this
objective remains and now
therefore
in this situation we propose to prolong
the system for one year so citizens can
continue to benefit
from this system having said that
it is not a permanent system that's very
clear that's why there is a prolongation
for
another year
and it is it remains an exceptional
measure
thank you francesco you have a question
on this issue
yes thanks just a little clarification
on the
tweak to the
uh for for the
for people who are participating in
trials
so the the the
which now according to this proposal
may be able to
receive a covet pass even if they are
effectively vaccinated with a vaccine
that is not yet
approved
because he's under treatment
the point is the question is
this is already the case in many states
who already are
giving certificates
to these people
otherwise would be very difficult to
enroll
participants for trials
so this is already happening
your proposal
doesn't seem to bring things
forward because it just says that
that
may be possible which is already the
case
and doesn't say anything about
acceptance of these certificates when
you travel which is another big problem
because obviously
a
participant in a trial wants to
be treated as a vaccinated person and be
able to travel across the eu
instead with this proposal there is no
obligation for member states to
recognize
a certificate issued by another state
to
trial participants can you clarify what
is actually
new in this proposal because it seems
that it's simply
replicating what is already happening in
some countries thanks
thank you christian
yeah i mean on on the on the clinical
trials
um indeed according to the proposal all
persons participating in in trials for
covered knight in vaccines
maybe issued an eu digital covert
certificate
so
they have to the possibility to get the
certificate
it will also be included in the same
harmonized validity period for
vaccination
certificate
and
yeah i mean this is this is basically
what we have what we have clarified and
that
it can and it can't be accepted i mean
uh francesco i mean thank you for the
question i think
the the
the fact is that the eu dcc as you know
is meant to facilitate travel uh within
the european union um and therefore uh
if you have an eu dcc that includes a
properly encoded uh
vaccine that you have received in the
context of a clinical trial it means
that this
is accepted when you travel within um
within the within the european union
this is how we understand it you have a
follow-up
so so are you saying that countries are
then
required to accept
this is not what you're writing in your
press release so are you saying that the
countries are now required if this
legislation is approved will be
obliged to accept
a certificate
issued by another new country
for for these people
so will they be obliged or not well
firstly let's just remember that this is
a proposal right so member states have
to uh have to accept it but once again
our understanding is that if it's in the
eu dcc
because the purpose of the eu dcc is to
allow travel within the european union
it means that you will then be able to
show this as a proof of vaccination for
the purposes of traveling
let's see
whether the legislator then adopts this
proposal as is of course
okay i see no further questions on this
on this issue
we continue with questions related to
the rule of law
for christian if there are any
um i believe i had seen leia's hand
leah
yes you can um it's not on rule of law
but i think it's for christian
well go ahead and see well go ahead and
see
uh it seems that the proposal on
sustainable corporate uh governance has
been again delayed to 23rd of february
so i wanted to see if we can have
some elements on why it has again been
delayed since it was the first year
to be published in
december
thank you
yeah this is just you know i mean
i think
i was asked this question uh
recently and indeed uh it was i think
for seen on the on the lpp
um on the 15th of february now it is uh
it is i think the week after but
as as
we always say and i think it's very
clear is that the list of pampers is
always indicative
um so i don't have any particular uh
reason here to flag there can be many
reasons for for setting the agenda of
the college
in any case
it remains true what i've what i've
said before that this is of course a
very important proposal for the
commission on which we are working at
full speed
and
which will be presented as soon as
possible
yeah if i can add a word leah we get
these questions all the time in the
press room and this is linked to the
fact that we're trying to help you
by making available what is basically an
internal planning document
where the points which are mentioned
changed all the time from one week to
the next every time the heads of cavalry
meet
they
they adapt did adapt sorry the list of
points
there are hundreds of reasons most of
them purely logistical or questions of
of travel arrangements of commissioners
of maturity of this or that specific
technical element that is required or
the wish to package things or to
unpackage things in terms of
presentation etc etc
and
therefore
you know we make this available
to you
um
with the assumption that you will
understand that we do this to facilitate
your work but that there are no we're
not going to be commenting politically
every single time on why a file moves by
one week two weeks a month or whatever
okay it's not linked to the fact that a
file is more or less
difficult it can be as well but in any
case
we are basically providing you this
information so that you can organize
your work and we will not be going into
each individual file and the details
related to why it's on the agenda one
day or another sometimes files move
from one week to the next simply because
a commissioner who was meant to be there
cannot be because he or she is on
mission et cetera et cetera i really
want to make that point uh clear
because we get this question all the
time and we're always providing the same
answer
okay
um are there other questions for
christian on his
portfolio
please keep your hand raised sabina i
know your question is for is not uh for
a christian so please help me manage
this
uh the right way um
can you raise your hand once again uh
once we have closed this issue anna you
have a question for christian go ahead
yes thank you can you hear me yes go
ahead yes go ahead yes christian this
question on another policy issue on tour
of the polish prime minister and czech
prime ministers
are supposed to
to sign an agreement today on tour of
mine i just wanted to ask i understand
that the
court of justice
stops proceeding when the czech republic
withdraw its it's complained against
poland but what about the penalties uh
uh what about the penalties counted you
know until until that moment because
from the moment the czech republic
withdraw its withdrawals complain
understand you you stop counting
calculating the the penalties but what
about the penalties
i calculated so so far
i mean have they
can you can you just you know annul them
and
also on this issue how much poland have
paid uh up to now on on this tour of
thing thank you
so this is actually not a question for
christian but for adelberg
um but it's somewhat related so we will
we will take it now
with his environment hat on believe it
or not
indeed it's a pleasure to be in the
press room with my green hat on again
regarding the
the upcoming announcement so far we've
only seen the announcements in the media
so we are none the wiser uh for now um
we will of course look into the
situation once once it becomes clearer
when it comes to the specific question
of the procedure and the penalties the
situation is as follows
if and when
the czech republic withdraws the case in
front of the european court of justice
then the interim measure
measures order that the court made would
also cease to apply
as of as of that date exactly right
which means that at as of that date the
daily penalties that poland
has to pay for non-compliance with that
order would also stop accruing
however any penalties that are due
up until that date would remain due and
and therefore would still have to be
would still have to be paid by by poland
of course there are two ways in which
these daily penalties can stop accruing
either
if um the czech republic withdraws its
case and then the case is closed or of
course if poland complies with
the interim measures order and now when
it comes to the question of um
how much has been paid so far this is
much more in the in the patch of balash
as it concerns the recovery yeah
good afternoon so um on the so-called
tour of case um the commission has now
sent four uh calls for payment
uh in that way we've covered the period
going from the 20th of september until
the 17th of um january now to my
knowledge um no payment has been uh
received from the polish authorities of
course we have a very clear established
procedure that we follow in this
particular particular case so
if you don't receive any payment by the
time the deadline of the first call for
payment passes then we send the
so-called reminder the second deadline
and then if the
payment is still not received then we
move on to what we call an office
setting a procedure so in the end the
commission has established ways of
recovering
the amounts of the fine
okay
on this
the water
how much money has been claimed
so far
so um every time we send a call for
payment to the polish authorities this
constitutes a
example for bilateral correspondence
with the member state which is why we
don't disclose the amount however um it
is clear that the daily penalty is half
a million euro and it's also clear
that the calls for payment concern
essentially four week periods so it's
fairly doable to to do a calculation uh
on
on your side as well um and of course
what has to be taken into account as
well is that when we send a second
letter then a
interest rate comes into the picture as
well based on article 99 of the
financial regulation more specifically
paragraph four section b
okay so for uh for how many days have
you claimed the money so far for how
what periods no the rota sorry but we're
not going to get into calculations and
stuff like that here we're happy to
continue the discussion bilaterally on
the exact number of days which changes
every day so we're not going to get into
the game here in the press room every
day of saying what is the number of days
that has
that this payment has been made i'm sure
you'll understand
anna you have another question on this
follow-up i guess
yeah yeah just just follow up because i
i
have you already recovered anything from
the payments that are due to poland
was it already the case or not
no and i think it's important to recall
an important element of the procedure
which is that
once the
once a payment is identified for off
setting the polish authorities will be
informed at least 10 working days
before uh the deduction is is made and i
believe then that's the case then we
will be at least making a basic point
about that so you will be informed when
such a letter is sent
oliver
on this
yes uh hi
um
[Music]
i think i did the math now and uh
i hope this isn't confidential
information but i think the number of
days
rises by one day
per day uh no but on a more serious note
can you explain to us
how does the opinion of the
um
of the european courts um that was
issued today on this case how does how
does the case as such how would that be
affected by an agreement between the
czech and the polish
governments if the checks in the polls
agree that uh
they are not going to argue over this
anymore is the case at the european
court then automatically over are there
i think european law uh issues that that
that are still uh affected by it does it
simply completely go away when they
agree on something
oliver oliver i think i think that uh
adelbert answered that question very
specifically
the uh case
the court case uh only stops if
czechia actually withdraws formally
notifies to the court that it is
withdrawing its complaint so a political
announcement per se
needs to be followed through
by a very specific legal step in front
of the european court of justice
defeat is this is it on this
because i had a long list of people
who wanted to raise questions so
is it on this is this working yeah
okay so um it's it's a sort of um
background i mean you talked about
offsetting so i was just wondering do
you have the discretion of where you
offset that money due
or
is that something that's automatic and
then
it's in the chat as well but it's
something that clears up um could could
you just repeat from when you say the
28th of september to the 17th of january
or could you start you know when it
starts and
up until when if you could explain that
thanks
yeah so in terms of the period again we
have sent four calls for payment each
concerning a period of approximately
four weeks so the period specifically
goes um from the 20th so from the 20th
of september until the 17th of january
so this this is the period that we've
covered with the first four calls for
payment which have been sent so far
now in terms of the of uh setting
procedure i think it's also important to
recall that this is the first time that
we are in a situation whereby um a
payment or a penalty imposed by the
court of justice related to a
non-compliance with a interim order by a
member state um
is is
the case so this is the very first time
that the commission has to do enough
setting procedure in this in this
context
um so what we need to do in this case is
to look at the upcoming uh payments that
there are always upcoming payments to
look at in in our
systems identify um a payment which is
sufficient for the off setting to be
made and once that's the case inform the
member state at least 10 working days
before the actual deduction is made
that's what we are working on at the
moment
okay
thanks for clarifying um right let's
close this chapter and move on to other
issues and i give the floor to sabina
who has been
consistently raising her hand in the
chat since the beginning
sabina if you are still with us you have
the floor
for rising my hand at the wrong time
my question is for ariana the
press reports today on marco monterey
pascal
and the attitude of the european
commission on this is it correct that
you consider the restructuring plan too
light or too weak
and is it true that you would welcome a
discontinuity in the board of director
and in particular the ceo position
thanks
something tells me you're going to be
disappointed by the answer
thank you eric thank you sabina so uh
indeed on the second part i have
absolutely no no comment as per our
usual practice and more generally what i
can say and i have already said in this
press room but i'm of course happy to
repeat is that the commission is closely
following the recent developments
concerning amanca monte pasque di siena
and is in contact with the italian
authorities on this matter in july 2017
we have approved italy's plan to support
the precautionary capitalization of mps
under your rules on the basis of an
effective restructuring plan and based
on certain commitments undertaken by
italy in relation to the bank
as always it's for member states to
comply with uh commitments and for them
to propose the ways in which these
commitments are fulfilled therefore it's
for italy to decide and propose ways on
how to exit the mmps ownership but
taking into consideration our 2017 state
aid decision
you ayanna are there other competition
questions for ariana while she's on the
podium
i only see one hand raised i'm not sure
it's um it's about
this no okay thank you ariana we opened
the floor to
other issues
uh
[Music]
perception
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
a question on the sahel
you need to speak you need to press
speak uh hi sorry uh actually my
questions i already wrote a note that
it's about ukraine and vienna talks so
i'm okay with it
they will come back to you later salaam
mass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
b
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
come back to you with your question i
believe on ukraine salaam go ahead
yes actually i have two questions one
about ukraine and the other about
vienna talks actually i'm wondering when
do you have the date for the resumption
of the talks in vienna and it will be i
don't know if it will be mid-february
the deadline as the e3 in boys we're
talking about uh
through several statements this is about
the nuclear deal networks and about the
ukraine uh i read a statement actually
or a priest release on your uh
on the website talking about the uh is
i'm sorry about the osce as uh the right
platform for the uh for the discussion
about ukraine so do you why don't you as
the eu try to have your direct channel
diplomatic channel with russia instead
of having the nato the us all the
osce thank you
salaam i think that that question the
second question we have answered a
million times here in the press room so
i would advise you to go and look at all
the recordings of our previous midday
briefings on the situation in ukraine or
to speak uh directly to uh to peter on
it we're not going to repeat every
single day our position when it comes to
the eu's role in managing this crisis
i believe your first question refers to
the talks on the gcpoa
i assume i passed the floor to peter on
this
hello good afternoon i hope you can hear
and see me so the situation is like uh
like following uh right now we are still
in the
midst of the eighth round of the talks
the talks have been uh uh taking a short
break last week and the participants
have been going back to their respective
capitals for important consultations and
crucial political instructions and this
eighth round of talks should resume
later this week we will make the
necessary announcement as appropriate
just to recall that this eighth round of
talks in vienna started already at the
end of december on december 27 with
daily meetings in different formats at
the expert and working levels so it was
expert level bilateral multilateral
meetings working groups and political
directors meetings took place regular
regularly to discuss the open issues and
then after this when the work is
completed and
agreement is found on all the issues
that are being discussed then a joint
commission is called and later on the
joint commission at the ministry level
but right now we are in the situation
when we have still the eighth round of
talks ongoing and they will resume
resume uh later this week in vienna
thank you are there other foreign
affairs related questions for us today
raf you have a question go ahead
yes uh i think it's also for peter it's
it's on russia and china uh i just
wanted uh there's going to be a meeting
in beijing uh tomorrow between putin and
lee
and putin has already had an interview
uh in which he said that uh the uh
non-showing of eu officials and other
european officials at the opening
ceremonies of the games is an attempt to
politicize sports to the to the benefit
of their ambitions so i would like to
have peter explain to us to what extent
we have such a low representation uh in
beijing
and then secondly lee has also had an
interview
in which he said that he sees this
combination of the western
the western actions against russia and
ukraine about ukraine and the issue of
taiwan
is in fact only driving both sides
together and
i would like to have your reaction to
that if possible too thank you
so the first question is actually uh for
nabila uh so i passed a law and then
peter yes um thanks raf for your
question i mean without wanting to
comment on on comments what i can tell
you is our position when it comes to
uh our presence to
to the
to the beijing olympics at the at a
diplomatic level
uh international sports institutions
have a primary responsibility in
organizing sports events at a global
level at the eu level this is an eu
member states competence in the fields
of sports while the eu
has a supporting role so this is uh this
position that we have we have already
said already on from this podium
we are of course fully committed to
contribute to promoting and protecting
sports integrity and to strengthening
universal respect for human rights big
sports events such as the olympic games
often have a universal audience they can
be instrumental for spreading positive
values and promoting freedom and human
rights at global level we are ready to
contribute to that however
such platforms should not be used for
political propaganda so this is
our position
and let me add that we wish best of luck
to all the athletes from eu member
states that will be competing at the
beijing olympics
um
right then on your second question i
give the floor to
peter
thank you very much but i think nabila
basically captured already everything
what we would say at this stage unless i
miss this a critical aspect of the
second part of the question
wrath
have we answered your questions to your
heart satisfaction
you need to press speak
okay um for some reason
you are not connecting so um i move uh
we move on to mumshit
hi good afternoon
uh today a new lawsuit has been filed
against
the already jailed and sentenced russian
opposition leader alexey navoni
uh is the european commission aware of
that and does it has does it have a
comment
peter
thank you we are following the situation
around mr navalny very closely so we
will of course analyze the details of
the latest lawsuit but i can only i can
only recall that in case of mr navalny
and we said it on many occasions he is
subject of
unlawful or injustified
from the side of russian authorities who
should really be focused first of all on
clarifying and investigating in a
transparent independent credible manner
the assassination attempt against his
life instead of trying to bring new and
new lawsuits against him
thank you
i see no further questions on foreign
affairs so we will close that chapter
are there questions on
other issues
perhaps this is on foreign affairs as
well i don't know
hold
on press speak please hear me yes go
ahead
okay so uh my question is on uh pushback
on the cases of pushbacks at the turkish
creek border
so yesterday turkish officials said uh
twelve piograms were found at the
greek turkish border
and turkish authors said that they were
frozen to death after being pushed back
by a greek authorities do you have any
information on that do you have any
comments to make
have you contacted greek authorities or
frantic authorities for an explanation
or
does the commission have any plans to
focus more on pushbacks
after this particular case thank you
very much such tragedies are always
awful and we regret obviously the loss
of life
i call anita to the podium for any other
elements that we can that we can provide
on this
thank you very much for uh for your
question indeed uh we have seen the
reports um
of by now 16 people who have lost their
lives at the greek turkish border and
indeed we deeply regret the loss of
lives and any such treatments if
confirmed to be true would be
intolerable
commissioner johansson has already
presented explained by eric is today in
lille at the informal jha council and in
close contact also with the greek
minister
on on this
issue
thank you are there other questions for
anita
on
home affairs
david
we merci i would like to know what do
you mean by close contact uh are you
asking information are you going to
push a little bit more your position on
on that issue which is quite recurrent
for uh greece thank you
sorry i think you can hear the alarm so
we will take we will pause until it's
over and then anita will answer
thank you so much david um this is
precisely what i have said in close
contact meaning that commissioner joe
hansen is personally speaking uh right
now
with the greek
minister uh in charge to uh to discuss
the incident and also to establish the
facts on on this
thank you
are there other questions on home
affairs
ontario
um
yes thank you
my question
is about president's calendar
i'd like to ask why
this visit to finland was organized
today or this week was there a specific
reason for it and i also would like to
ask why commission presidents is
tweeting the eu has full solidarity for
finland
is there a specific reason that
commission wants to express their full
solidarity to finland right now at this
moment thank you
thank you well um as we said i think
there is a press conference which is
starting in a few minutes in finland so
as you can i'm sure completely
understand
it's not for me to
to speak on behalf of the president just
as she is about to speak as to why a
meeting to finland was organized this
week
well as you know the president is in
close contact uh with all the member
states on many different issues but in
particular obviously on the situation
in ukraine in and around and ukraine and
and therefore it is entirely legitimate
and appropriate that she has personal
contacts with leaders of different
member states
she has been traveling quite extensively
you remember perhaps that she went to
the baltic states
recently in view of the tensions
at the belarussian
border there does not need to be a
specific event for the president
to meet her close her contacts at the
highest levels in the different
in the different member states but we
take the opportunity obviously to
discuss
the situation every time that an
opportunity arises
okay i see no other question on this in
any case as i said there will soon be a
press conference i think i had said at 3
50 at 1 15 by which point in time we
will close this mid-day briefing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
adam
[Music]
[Music]
you